President Barack Obama State of the  Union address as I said one moment  everyone was talking about was when they  cut to Secretary of Energy dr. Ernest  Moniz listening in the audience check it  out and today America is number one in  oil and gas America is number one in  wind power every three weeks we bring  online as much solar power as we did in  all of 2008  well Twitter and the rest the internet  were immediately obsessed with this guy  so guess what we flew him to our show  tonight say hello to your Secretary of  Energy dr. Ernest Moniz  welcome glad to have you here it's  really cool you're here okay  all right can you talk secretary moniz  oh you can could you mind saying  something right now okay  okay what if we were to give you a giant  lollipop  okay let's give my lollipop someone give  him a giant lollipop I think he's gonna  yeah there we go  there we go oh isn't that nice you like  that touch will you speak now it's like  if the Quaker Oats guy was a pervert  you